[Musique]
il semble que mika est vraiment mal
évalué la situation
il a mal évalué la résistance du peuple
ukrainien années il a surestimé les
capacités à son armée avait assuré une
victoire rapide poutine s'est sentie
trompée par l'armée russe ce qui a
entraîné des tensions persistantes entre
lui et ses dirigeants militaires nous
pensons qu'il est mal informée par ses
conseillers sur la mauvaise performance
de son armée parce que ses conseillers
principaux ont trop peur de dire la
vérité nous avons
à court d'armes jour de morale
refusé d'exécuter les ordres saboter
leurs propriétés même abattre
accidentellement leurs propres avions et
renseignements britanniques et
américains ce sont eux qui avaient
annoncé que les russes allaient attaquer
il avait vu juste contrairement aux
français on a d'ailleurs appris le
limogeage du général éric vidaud le
directeur des renseignements militaires
à l'europe n'a quoi parler d'une seule
voix et essaye d'avoir une réponse
commune dans ce profil d'une seule voix
la mairie
les allemands qui ont dit tu allais
pouvoir reconstituer votre votre mii
votre armée elle s'en va acheter des
avions américains nous appelle ça une
europe qui se reconstitue pendant que la
pologne est le même aussi demande de son
aide aux états unis et achète des avions
américains avec probablement l'argent
que la france verse à l'europe qui lui
est reversé puisque nous sommes un pays
qui contribuent plus qu'ils ne reçoivent
pendant que la pologne reçoit plus
qu'elles ne contribuaient et demain les
européens devront payer leur gaz
uniquement en roubles c'est ce
qu'indique ce décret du jour signée par
vladimir poutine si ces paiements ne
sont pas effectués nous considérerons
qu'il s'agisse d'un défaut de paiement
avec les conséquences qui en découlent
pour lieu qui importent 155 milliards de
mètres cubes par an soit 40 % de sa
consommation depuis la russie une telle
décision aurait de lourdes conséquences
notamment sur les prix pour le
consommateur peut y avoir une situation
dans laquelle demain pour des
circonstances très particulières
il n'y aurait plus de gaz russe donc
c'est à nous de préparer ces scénarios
là
mon adversaire c'est le scénario écrit
par le système emmanuel macron on ne
veut pas avoir en face de lui une droite
républicaine forte avec un vrai projet
de rupture qui met en cause son bilan je
respecte le tout les françaises tous les
français croient qu'ils croient mais il
ya un tandem qui est là en train
d'avancer avec des idées d'extrême
droite on connaît depuis longtemps sont
portés par un clan et un nouveau venu il
ya 60 ans ou 40 % de participation ça
serait un drame national mais un drame
c'est une chose pas valable c'est une
autre à valable dans le coeur des gens
parce que j'ai voulu dire
quand le système politique quand le sol
est
légitime ben pour moi non beaucoup de
nos concitoyens ne savent pas encore
s'ils vont aller voter pour qu'ils vont
aller voter et même qu'ils envisagent
s'ils ont déjà une idée de pouvoir
changer de votes donc voilà et c'est une
grande majorité de nos concitoyens et
moi je m'adresse à eux tout s'effondre
une espèce de nihilisme généralisée et
des manteaux bira par ne part pas ne
part plus mélenchon est adoubé par des
gens dont il ne veut pas hein et puis
enfin zemmour démarre en disant qu'il
est gaullien un gaulliste il finit avec
le portrait de napoléon derrière lui un
bon vin un bon fromage mais aussi une
bonne vieille une bonne bière
parce que
le chiffre du jour entre 2,4 et 2,6 pour
cent c'est la hausse annoncée du smic
pour le 1er mai prochain petite
augmentation du pouvoir d'achat qui fait
suite à la forte inflation
2603 euros brut par mois le salaire
minimum pourra donc atteindre jusqu'à
1600 47 euros bruce willis qui prend sa
retraite ap après plus de trente ans de
carrière lecteurs américains souffrent
d'aphasie une maladie qui impacte ses
capacités cognitives
moi j'ai confiance
[Musique]